Hello. Hello.
[Music]
Hello. Hello. Test. Test. Test. Test.
Test test.
[Music]
Just
we're having an issue. We can't
>> we've test
[Music]
Walking forward.
Hello.
>> Huh?
>> Hello.
[Music]
So, I'm really excited.
Hallelujah.
[Music]
Christ.
I've seen you guys.
[Music]
I didn't like it. I returned.
>> Yeah. So, I'm done.
[Music]
Hey, Good evening and welcome.
We're so glad you're here. My name is
Cat and my pronouns are she, her.
And as we
make our way in tonight, um I have a
couple of things to bring your attention
to. Our unbound service and first Sunday
meal will be in the family life center
um on August 3rd that we are service
and potluck and share. No, I don't know
if potluck you or not. If it doesn't say
here, I better not. Um anyway, if
anybody knows that, let me know. Uh but
anyway, it's the unveil services
combined and um it was really great last
time and the fellowship is great. So we
hope you guys will join us and think
about that.
If you're anxious about being in a
church setting,
um we have um some things over in that
bucket, coloring sheets, fidget
spinners, fiddly things. Uh you're
welcome um to go and use those. These
candles
are a sign of the presence of Christ
among us
fully divine and fully human.
Now as we
exit the kingdom of noise, hurry,
productivity,
now we enter the kingdom of silence,
stillness,
and grace.
Now we enter sacred space.
A space for prayer,
worship, adoration,
a space to encounter Christ,
revelation of God, heartbeat of
creation.
Allow the unforced rhythms of grace to
find you,
to mend your heart.
May we all come home.
Well, good evening everyone. If you want
to go ahead and stand with us.
[Music]
We're going to start with a really
beautiful song that I tend to pick.
Pretty much anytime I am allowed to pick
the songs, I pick this one.
So, here we go.
You are not
what you have done
or what has
been done to you.
You are something
like the rising sun. Can you see
you are new?
You might have
your father's name
or bear the shame
he left behind.
But there's new life flowing
through your veins. Can you see to be
surprised?
You are new
every morning.
every morning. Each day resurrection
waiting to break through.
Yeah.
You could try
just for a start
to put the judge
back on the shelf.
All the loving
kindness
in your heart. Have a little
for yourself.
You are new
every morning.
every morning. Each day resurrection
waiting to break through.
You think hope is lost when it's just
underground.
The flame might be ine but the fire
won't go out.
All the evidence is pointing to the
truth.
That daily resurrection
is still happening.
You are new
every morning.
You are new.
Every morning
you are new.
Every morning, each day resurrection,
waiting to break through.
You are new.
All right, kiddos. That's your Q.
Huge thank you to our kids ministry.
They are the real MVPs.
So now we're going to enter into a time
called prayers of the people.
I'll read the leader part. You guys are
the all. That's your identity for this
part.
For this city of Saxi, Texas, and for
every city and community, and all who
live in them, we pray to you
for the good earth you have given us,
and the wisdom and will to conserve it.
We pray to you for the old and the sick,
for the widow and orphan, for the
injured and suffering. We pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed, the
unemployed and destitute, for prisoners
and captives, and all who remember and
care for them. We pray to you
for the vulnerable, the marginalized,
and those unjustly targeted for their
gender, sexuality, race, or other
perceived difference. We pray to you for
those experiencing loss, loneliness, and
disconnection. And for those struggling
with mental and emotional health, we
pray to you.
Lord, we know that you love us, that you
hear us. So we lift these names and
situations up to you.
[Music]
For the names and moments we have spoken
aloud and for those we have kept in our
hearts. We pray to you that they may
have life and light, healing and hope,
peace and a deep sense of your presence.
And in my mother's womb,
you formed me with your hands. Known in
love by you
before I took a breath. When I doubted,
Lord, remind me. I'm wonderfully made.
You're an artist and a potter. I'm the
canvas and the clay.
You make all things
work together
for my future
and for my good. You make all things
work together
for your glory
and for your name.
There's a healing light
just beyond the clouds. Though I've
walked through fire,
I see clearly now. I know nothing has
been wasted.
No failure or mistake. You're an artist
and a part of the canvas and grave.
You make all things
work together
for my future
and for my good. You make all things
work together
for your glory
and for your name.
for your name.
And when I doubt it, Lord, remind me.
I'm wonderfully made. You're an artist
and a potter. I'm the canvas and the
clay. And I know nothing has been
wasted.
No failure or mistake.
You're an artist and aarter from the
canvas and the clay. And when I doubt
it, Lord, remind me. I'm wonderfully
made. You're an artist and a partner.
I'm the
clay. And I know nothing has been
wasted.
No failure or mistake.
You're an artist and a parter of the
chemist and the clay.
[Applause]
[Music]
You're not finished with me.
You're not finished with me. Yeah.
You're not finished with me yet. You're
not finished with me. No. You're not
finished with me yet.
You make all things
work together
for my future
and for my good. You make all things
work together
for your glory.
[Music]
and for your name he make all things
work together
for my future
and for my good make all things
work together
[Music]
for your glory
and for your name.
[Music]
How can I respond
to the love that you have lavished on
me?
How can I respond
to the love that you have lavished on
me?
I don't have much.
I don't have much,
but I have a heart that beats for you. I
have a heart that beats for you.
I don't have much.
But I have a heart that beats for you. I
have a heart that beats for you.
Every part of me
wants to love you like you loved me.
Oh,
every part of me
wants to love you like you loved me.
My Lord,
I don't have much.
I don't have much, but I have a heart
that beats for you. I have a heart that
beats for you. I don't have much.
I don't have much, but I have a heart
that beats for you. I have a heart that
beats for you. I have a heart that beats
for you. I have a heart that beats for
you. I have a heart that beats for you.
I have a heart that beats for you. I
have a life I'll give to you. I have a
life I'll give to you. I have a life
I'll give to you. I have a life I'll
give to. I have a heart that beats for
you. I have a heart that beats for you.
I have a heart that beats for you. I
have a heart that beats for you. I have
a life I'll give to you. I have a life
I'll give to you. I have a life I'll
give to you. I have a life I'll give to
you.
I don't have much.
I have a heart that beats for you. I
have a heart that beats for you.
I don't have much.
I don't have much, but I have a heart
that beats for you. I have a heart that
beats for you.
[Music]
Jesus, we come to you not with very
much,
but what we have is all we've got.
In the midst of
just horrifying, chaotic things we see
around the world right now,
all we have is our beating heart.
So Jesus, we offer you what we have.
We pray that you would multiply the good
and comfort and encourage our weary
hearts.
[Music]
Open our ears, our minds,
our souls to what you have for us
tonight.
We ask this in your name. Amen. Before
you sit down, go ahead and turn around
and uh pass the peace of Christ.
[Music]
Hello every Can you hear me? No. Yes. Oh
yes. Fantastic. Okay. My name is
Christian. I am one of the elders here
and I've been a member for a few years.
Um, for people who are new, uh, our
church looks a little different during
the month of July. Um, mainly because,
um, and I was I was talking to Brett,
our pastor, yesterday, and uh, I made a
joke that he fasts from church during
the month of July. So, but he takes a
kind of a sbatical break during the
month to kind of recoup and plan for the
rest of the year. and uh and so does
some members of our worship team. And so
we're a little smaller, but a great
wonderful group that's here. Um during
the month of July, another thing that we
do, which is I think is super cool, um
and actually when my wife and I first
started coming here, we uh we actually
came in during July uh was that we got
to see
people within the congregation or
friends of the congregation come in and
do sermons. And so, um, that's what we
have today is we have a guest that will
be doing a sermon today. Um, so I'd like
to, uh, introduce her. Um, I would like
to introduce Denise Mason. She is the
pastor of Pleasant Va Valley United
Methodist Church. Pleasant Valley is
where the table um, used to hold our
services until we moved to this space.
And so, she's been a good friend of our
church and a cheerleader for us. Um she
is a uh child of missionaries. Uh she's
grown up all over the world before
choosing to answer God's call to
ministry about 15 years ago. Uh she and
her high school sweetheart Mike have
five children and 10 grandchildren.
Can you please give a warm welcome to
Denise?
[Applause]
I don't know if I should stand up here
or down there. While I'll stand up here.
Let's hopefully this goes up.
Thank you all for having me. I can't
tell you how much I miss this
congregation uh when you used to meet um
at Pleasant Valley. It was always such a
wonderful thing. I would stay in my
office until people started coming in
because I loved seeing everyone come in.
So, I'm just really appreciative for
that. Uh Brett asks me back
occasionally. Glad to be here today. Um
I wanted to read to you from the book of
Exodus. Today we're going to look at
Exodus 16:es 1-15.
Hear now these words. The whole
congregation of the Israelites set out
from Elm and came to the wilderness of
Sin, which is between Elm and Si on the
15th day of the second month after they
had departed from the land of Egypt.
The whole congregation of the Israelites
complained against Moses and Aaron in
the wilderness.
The Israelites said to them, "If only we
had died by the hand of the Lord in the
land of Egypt, when we sat by the pots
of meat and ate our fill of bread, for
you have brought us out into this
wilderness to kill this whole assembly
with hunger."
Then the Lord said to Moses, "I am going
to rain bread from heaven for you, and
each day the people shall go out and
gather enough for that day. In that way,
I will test them whether they will
follow my instructions or not.
On the sixth day, when they prepare what
they bring in, it will be twice as much
as they gather on the other days."
So Moses and Aaron said to all the
Israelites, "In the evening you shall
know that it was the Lord who brought
you out of the land of Egypt, and in the
morning you shall see the glory of the
Lord, because he has heard your
complaining against the Lord. For what
are we that you complain against us?"
And Moses said, 'When the Lord gives you
meat to eat in the evening and your fill
of bread in the morning, because the
Lord has heard the complaining that you
utter against him, what are we? Your
complaining is not against us, but
against the Lord.
Then Moses said to Aaron, say to the
whole congregation of the Israelites,
draw near to the Lord, for he has heard
your complaining. And as Aaron spoke to
the whole congregation of the
Israelites, they looked towards the
wilderness, and the glory of the Lord
appeared in the cloud.
The Lord spoke to Moses.
I've heard the complaining of the
Israelites, say to them, "At twilight
you shall eat meat, and in the morning
you shall have your full of fill of
bread, and you shall know that I am the
Lord your God."
In the evening, quailes came up and
covered the camp. And in the morning
there was a layer of dew around the
camp. When the layer of dew lifted,
there on the surface of the wilderness
was a fine flaky substance as fine as
frost on the ground.
When the Israelites saw it, they said to
one another,
"What is it?"
This is God's word for God's people
today. Thanks be to God. Would you pray
with me?
Come, Holy Spirit.
May the words of my mouth and the
meditations of our hearts be acceptable
in your sight. A rock and our redeemer.
Amen.
Now, it doesn't seem to matter how old
you are. There is something about summer
that screams freedom, right? And I'm
sure it stems from our childhoods when
we'd wait with baited breath for that
great and glorious day when school was
finally over for the year. If you were
like me, it was that day when the future
stretched before me, like it was filled
with endless possibilities of adventure
and fun. Of course, it never panned out
to be everything I hoped it would be,
but nevertheless, every year the dream
lived on.
Now, as you heard earlier, I grew up a
missionary kid in places like Lebanon,
Egypt, Nepal, and India. We left the US
when I was 7 years old and for the rest
of my childhood I only came home until I
came home for college I only came home
twice to the US. Once when I was 11 and
the second time when I was 16. Now there
were many summers we went to wonderful
places and saw wonderful things. But
without a doubt the best summers I
remember were those two summers
when my parents see my parents had to
come home and do a lot of stuff on
furlow. But my brother and my sister and
I knew one thing. When we came home, we
got to go to grandma's house, and that
was the most exciting thing we could
think about. We would we would go to
this small clapboard house built in the
1800s down in a town south of Houston
about 90 miles that had nothing going
for it. absolutely zero going for it
except for a feisty old woman who
thought we hung the moon and two aunts
who well frankly we thought we hung the
moon too. So after weeks of preparation
anticipation while the car would finally
be packed we kids would be loaded in the
car. Mom and dad would be in the front
seat. The maps were out and we were off.
Yippee.
For the first 100 miles or so, the four
of us in the back seat. Well, we managed
to get along really well. We would talk
about what we were going to do when we
got to grandma's house. We were talk
about how much everyone had missed us,
how happy they would be to see us,
because after all, we were the center of
the universe and all the wonderful
things we could get to buy when we got
there at the Ben Franklin, the glorious
Ben Franklin. We would sing songs and we
would pay play the license alphabet
game, if you know what that is. It was
glorious. It was harmonious. It was
idyllic.
But then I would say something like,
"Hey, look at that cactus." And my
brother would say, "Hey, look at that
cactus.
Stop." I would yell. Stop. He would say
right after me. I am telling mom, I
would yell. I'm telling mom. Like she
couldn't hear any of this. Mom. And it
just went downhill from there. About the
time that we would get all that died
down. Well, then my sister would start
up with a really annoying song. This is
the song that never ends. Yes, it goes
on and on, my friend. By that time, my
brother and I would start yelling, "Sh,
stop. Stop. Mom, make her stop." And my
mother would say, "She can sing if she
wants to." Well, it just would devolve.
It would devolve. about the time the
song that never ends ended. Well, that
would be when my brother would pipe up
from little brother would pipe up and
say, "I'm starving. I'm so hungry." And
then the rest of us who were tired of
being in the car at that point, well,
yes, we would start acting like we were
fainting from hunger in the back seat
until my parents would pull over. pull
over into a rest stop, usually one that
had those little metal teepeees where
the picnic tables were about 250 degrees
and you had to put something over them
so you could sit down. And no lie, my
dad would open the hood of the car, pull
out a foil package of hot dogs that he
had had cooking on the engine block the
entire time we were driving. No lie.
Well, this was really exciting. and my
mom would pull out the buns and the
chips and on that first day we would
stuff ourselves like it was the last
meal we would ever have because it was
novel and we loved hot dogs.
By the second day, however, hot dogs
wrapped in aluminum foil and cooked on
the engine block had for some reason
kind of lost its appeal. And by the
third day, after another forced scenic
bypass my mother would make us go on to
see some kind of cactus tree that looked
like every other cactus tree in the
world, well, we were all ready to
revolt.
Looking out at the unchanging desert
scenery that looked devoid of any human
civilization, we would start whining and
crying. Why can't we have real food? Why
can't we stop at McDonald's? Why do we
have to eat in stupid teepeees? And why
is this taking so long?
I think it's safe to say that's much the
same feeling that the Israelites had as
they began their third month following
Moses in the Sinai Peninsula. When they
left Egypt, it was easy to be pumped up.
God through Moses had parted the sea,
allowed them to walk on dry land to the
other side. God had destroyed their
enemy. God was with them. They were
headed to the promised land. land of
milk and honey, a land which God had
promised to give them. But two months
later, well, here they are. They're
stuck in the middle of the desert
following an old man. There's nothing
out here. There's no food. There's no
water. They're going deeper and deeper
into this place where life cannot
possibly be sustained.
Why did we follow this old guy anyway?
What in the world were we thinking?
We're surely going to starve out here.
And then they turned to one another and
said, 'W wait a minute. Why are we even
doing this? It would have been better if
we just died in Egypt. I mean, at least
we would be buried on familiar ground. I
know Moses told us some story about God
leading us to the promised land, but
this is ridiculous. All we can see is
sand and more sand. We have nothing to
eat. Why did we ever start on this trip?
The text tells us that God hears their
complaining and he tells Moses to tell
the people that at twilight they're
going to eat meat and in the morning
they will see the full glory of the Lord
because God will send bread from heaven
and they will eat their fill. I'll do
this every day. God says it will be only
good for one day. They can't hoard. They
they can't keep extra for later.
Everyone will have enough. No one will
have extra. God will do this. And when
they see it, they will know that the
Lord is God.
And that evening, quail settle into the
camp, and the Israelites have meat and
they're happy enough.
But bread,
bread is what they long for. Bread is so
comforting. It's familiar. So the next
morning, they get up expectantly, but
all they see is this layer of dew.
And when the dew lifts, they see this
fine, flaky substance on the ground.
something that looks like frost.
And the people look at it and they they
look at each other and they say, "What
is this?
What is this? Where is our bread?"
They'd been promised a land of milk and
honey. But instead, they're wandering in
the wilderness, this precarious place,
place of uncertainty, an unfamiliar
place where fear rules.
And just when they feel a little bit of
hope, what's dashed?
They expect bread. And they know what
bread looks like. But this,
what is this?
Mana.
See, although we assume that mana is the
name of the heavenly bread that God
provided, in reality, the Hebrew word
mana translates as what is this
mana? The children of Israel ask and
Moses replies, "This is bread. This is
the bread God has given you. It just
looks different from any bread you've
had before, so you don't recognize it,
but this is the bread from God. Bread
from heaven."
In the late 1990s, I found myself taking
another road trip.
This one not nearly as exciting and this
one more of a metaphorical road trip.
is one I didn't ask to go on. I didn't
want to go on. One I couldn't seem to
get out of, though.
After 19 years of being a stay-at-home
mom to five children, well, my two
oldest children graduated from college,
sorry, from high school, and they left
home to go to college. Right about the
same same time that my husband's job
moved us to a different state.
Now, to say I missed my kids was an
understatement, and the move just added
insult to injury.
But that was really just the beginning
because over the next four years, we
moved four more times. Situation that
left both me and my family in a constant
state of disruption.
By the time we made our fifth move,
which led us back to Texas, while our
oldest daughter had just married and
moved to Chicago, our son Nicholas had
left to go to Japan to teach English for
three years, and our third child was
leaving home to go to college at Texas
A&M.
already reeling with the changes and the
loss of my family as I knew it. Well, I
developed some medical problems and over
the course of the next 12 months, I
required three major surgeries.
I was drowning.
I couldn't seem to swim, but there was
more to come. Just as I was recovering
from my last surgery, when my beloved
sister developed a lump in her breast
and discovered it, which turned out to
be an extremely aggressive form of form
of breast cancer.
As all this piled up, I remember waking
up one morning wondering how I was going
to even get out of bed.
The world is I knew it was spinning out
of control. And although I prayed and I
prayed, no amount of praying and crying
seemed to make any difference to my
circumstances.
And all I could think was, I want my old
life back.
Please God, just let me have my old life
back. I know I complained sometimes
then, but it was so much better. Please,
God,
please.
But it just seemed as if my prayers were
all just going up into the ether. Or
God, if God was really there, well,
didn't seem to care.
As time went on, I went from sad and
weepy to angry.
My friends would sympathize and they
would cluck their tongues and try and
plate me by saying things like, "God
loves you so much. Don't you just feel
it? Can't you just feel the love and the
comfort God is pouring out on you?
And I would look around and I'd think,
"No,
I don't feel it. I think God's left the
building."
I had lived my whole life following what
I believed to be God's will for me. I
had sacrificed for my husband's job. I
had sacrificed for my children. I'd
given everything up to be a good person,
a loving person. And look where it led
me. to a place where loneliness
threatened to overwhelm me, where
anxiety seemed to be my constant
companion and a place where my three
oldest children were scattered across
the world.
My health was suffering. My sister was
forced to undergo two years of a
intensive chemotherapy regimen after a
double mastctomy.
This was not the life I wanted.
What is this?
Have you ever been there?
Traveling down the highway of on of life
on our way somewhere great when suddenly
you find yourself in a wilderness with
teepee picnic tables that are 250
degrees.
A place where all seems barren, where
fear and anxiety and grief and sorrow
threaten to overwhelm you.
A place where you pray over and over,
"Please, God, please." But it seems like
God isn't listening.
Because what you receive looks nothing
like what you want or what you asked
for.
What is this?
Mana,
I want my old life back. Why is this
happening? When is it going to be over?
After a number of years of wandering
down that wilderness road, I was invited
by a friend who was my pastor at the
time and knew a little bit about what I
was going through to join a small group
of women from the church. We were going
to go on a 4-day retreat.
We were going to a monastery located on
a ranch in South Texas, a place that was
very isolated, and all of us were going
to have our own individual cabins, but
we were to eat together with the monks
and the hermits that lived on the
property.
Now, the break from the everyday worry
and stress and grind. Well, it seemed
sounded pretty wonderful to me. Even
when I learned that the monastery was
well, they practice strict silence. No
talking at all except Sundays during
lunch.
We could meet together once a day to
receive holy communion, but no talking.
Silent or not, I was all too ready to
go.
And we arrived one sunny spring day and
we were shown to our cabins and we were
told we were free to roam anywhere as
far as we wished because there were
walking paths all throughout the ranch.
So I immediately changed my clothes, put
on my tennis shoes, and went out to
explore
with nothing to distract me, no friends
to talk to, no worry about polite
conversation. Well, I walked and I
walked and I walked and I walked. And as
I walked, well, I found myself getting
more and more feeling more and more
sorry for myself. And I began to talk to
myself and to God out loud. I complained
about my life. I cried. And then I
complained all over again.
Mile after mile, I walked until I was
exhausted.
And I stopped in front of a tree with a
lowhanging branch. and I decided to
climb it because I'm me. And as I lay
back on the tree and I looked up through
the branches into the pristine blue sky,
I suddenly started humming.
I started humming and then I started
singing.
This is my father's world.
And to my listening ears all nature
sings and round me rings the music of
the spheres.
And as I sang, I was suddenly struck
with how much I had changed. How much
stronger I had become over the last
number of years. How I had seemed to
find a part of me that I didn't even
know existed.
The years had been hard. They'd been
tougher than anything I could ever
imagine. And they were frankly still
tough. But in this moment, in this place
here and now, I realized that in spite
of myself, I had learned a lot.
learned things about myself. I learned
things about my family, things about the
nature, about the true nature of
friendship and love.
And I kept singing.
When I got to the last verse, I began to
cry.
This is my father's world. Oh, let me
never forget that though the wrong seems
off so strong, God is the ruler. Yet
this is my father's world. Why should my
heart be sad? The Lord is king. Let the
heavens ring. God reigns. Let the earth
be glad.
When I finished singing, I felt this
sense of peace come over me.
It suddenly seemed like a light had been
switched on. And in that light, I
suddenly saw everything differently.
In that moment, I knew beyond a shadow
of a doubt that my anger, my fear, all
of that, in the middle of it, God was
not absent.
God had been walking beside me all
along.
God had been feeding me.
I just didn't recognize it.
See, while I was longing for my familiar
bread, God was giving me something else.
I wanted my kids to come back home to
stay with me.
Yet, when my son called from Japan to
tell me how much he missed us, how much
he loves us, I didn't recognize the
bread from heaven. Mana,
rejoice. You did a good job raising him.
or when my oldest daughter called asking
me to come and visit to help her
decorate her new home because mom,
you're the only one who makes the house
feel like a home.
Nana,
be thankful.
You are appreciated.
Or when my sister wanted me to be with
her at chemo because sisters are the
only ones who can watch each other
vomit.
Sisters are the only ones that can shave
your head and tell you you are beautiful
bald
man.
You're beloved
and there's only one of you.
Or when a friend asked me to come on a
retreat because she knew I was
struggling.
A friend who later found me a job that
led me into pastoral ministry. Mana,
you matter.
I have plans for you that are beyond
your wildest imagination.
My friends, no one wants to take a road
trip through the wilderness.
The children of Israel certainly didn't.
The fact is, we would all much rather
get straight to grandma's house, right?
The road is dusty. The scenery is just
sand and more sand and food is scarce.
There are days when despair takes over.
Days when the promised land seems like
nothing more than a pipe dream.
Days when you look around and you say,
"What is this?"
But if you are on that road,
I pray you will hear my words today.
Do not lose heart.
Do not despair.
Because despite the scenery, despite the
hunger and thirst, despite the way you
may feel or think, God has not left the
building,
God has not abandoned you.
God has not abandoned any of us.
God is on that trip with us, providing
bread that is enough for today,
even though we may not recognize it.
Mana
in a phone call just at the right
moment.
Mana in a friend who shows up with soup
when you're too tired to cook.
Mana in silence and a tree to rest in.
Mana in a song you forgot you knew until
it rose from your soul
when words had run out.
Mana,
bread from heaven
for th those who have eyes to see.
I'm sorry about that. For those who have
eyes to see and have ears to hear, my
friends, God is providing what we need
for today.
It looks a lot different than the food
we think we really want.
But my friends, it is the food we need.
It is the food that nourishes our souls.
The food that draws us closer to one
another. The food that forms us. Food
that sustains us and carries us through
any wilderness we may find ourselves in.
Our road trip may be a long one,
but we will get to the promised land
because the God who brought the people
of Israel out of slavery and oppression,
the God who provided for them in the
wilderness, my friends, is still at work
in the world today, guiding us and
providing for us.
There is a promised land ahead.
how far we don't know.
But we can trust that the Lord our God
who led God's children to the land of
milk and honey, the God who sent Jesus
to show us how much we are loved, the
God who promises never to abandon us,
will lead us safely there.
Thanks be to God.
Amen.
of holy communion. I want to give you a
few instructions.
First and foremost, I am supposed to do
communion right now. Am I not Jesse?
>> Yeah, you do.
>> Okay, good. Okay. First and foremost, um
I wanted to let you know that this table
is an open table. No matter who you are,
no matter what age you are, no matter
where you are on your spiritual journey,
this table is open to you because this
table is the table of Jesus Christ. And
he invites us here and he offers us
grace upon grace. He invites us to come
and eat, come receive healing,
forgiveness, and hope. come and
experience
love that has no boundaries.
When I'm done blessing the elements, we
will invite you to come through the
center aisle. And please know that the
white is grape juice and the red is
wine. And we'll start from the front and
work to the back.
Would you pray with me?
Merciful God, as we prepare to come to
your table of grace, we confess that we
have sinned against you in thought,
word, and deed. By what we have done and
what we have left undone,
we have not loved you with our whole
heart. We have not loved our neighbors
as ourselves.
We justly deserve your judgment.
Oh God,
for the sake of your son, Jesus Christ,
have mercy on us. Forgive us. renew us
and lead us so that we may delight in
your will and walk in your ways that
lead to glory.
Amen.
Let us now remember that on the night in
which our Lord was betrayed, he took
bread.
He gave thanks to you, oh God. He broke
the bread, gave it to his disciples, and
said, "Take and eat.
This is my body which is given for you.
Do this in remembrance of me.
And when the supper was over, Jesus took
the cup. He gave thanks to you, oh God.
He gave it to his disciples and said,
"Drink from this all of you. This is my
blood of the new covenant poured out for
you and for many for the forgiveness of
sins. Do this as often as you drink it
in remembrance of me.
And so, gracious God, we now ask that
you pour out your Holy Spirit upon this
bread and cup and upon each one of us
that by sharing in this banquet
together, we might become one with you,
one with each other, and strengthened to
go out into the world to build your
kingdom, to love, and to serve all we
meet as we follow the one called Jesus
the Christ.
Amen.
My friends, come to the table. It's made
ready for those who love him, for those
who want to love him more. So come, you
who have faith and you who have little.
You who have been here often and you who
have not been here long.
You who have tried to follow and you who
have failed.
Come because Jesus invites you here.
Come to the table.
Amen.
[Music]
Well, I I will say that that was a
pretty timely message.
I'm sure it was for many people, but I
was really feeling that one tonight.
Thank you so much, Denise. It's always
such a such a honor to have you with us.
And just like a lot of your stories,
like we miss you. We really miss you. We
really do.
Uh, and I think uh, again, it happened
two weeks in a row. Denise and I did not
talk about songs. Um, but this one uh,
fit really well. So, if you'd like to
stand with us as we sing this together.
We're start with You Think Hope is Lost.
You think hope is lost, but it's just
underground.
The flame might be an amber, but the
fire won't go out.
All the evidence is pointing to the
truth.
That daily resurrection
is still happening in you. You are new
every morning.
You are new
[Music]
every morning.
You are new
Each day resurrection
waiting to break through.
You are new.
[Music]
Thank you so much for joining us this
evening.
If you are new,
we would love for you to fill out a card
on the table on your way out or you can
scan the QR code um and fill out some an
online um
card just to give us a little
information and we can thank you for
being here.
Generosity is a key aspect of life of
adoration and worship. If you would like
to give financially, if you are a member
of this community and you would like to
support this community, um you may go uh
to the QR code or you may visit the
table at the tabletx.org.
And if you call the table home but don't
current currently
have a meetup, you may also go online
and look at our different meetups and
find locations
um and times and days that will work for
you. Meetups um meetups are neat. Um,
you know, I can say that with Suzanne
and I, we're in a couple and it's it's
very important. Um, it's filling. So,
and also if you call the table home and
you don't currently have a or have
joined or you are interested in joining
a ministry, we have several that we
would welcome you with open arms,
hospitality, and the welcoming and and
the greeting and the setting up the
little elves that set up
before you arrive and take it down. Uh
also uh tech team, the ones who make us,
you know, makes it work.
And then our fabulous um ministry team,
our praise team. So you can also um go
on to uh QR code and go to the table um
and visit the tx.org and find a find a
ministry that works for you.
All right.
I would like to send you
out on your week
with this blessing. You may hold your
hand out in a posture to receive or just
open your heart to these words.
You are a child of God.
You
are a child of God.
This is true on your best day
and this is true on your worst day.
[Music]
So as you go out into your week ahead
with its yet to be determined highs and
lows and whatever lies in between.
Go filled with the assurance
that you are loved,
you are worthy,
and you are accepted just as you are.
And go
filled with God's Holy Spirit
and the desire
to extend these same gifts of grace and
unconditional love to everyone you come
in contact with.
be blessed. Have a good week
and we hope to see you back here next
Sunday. Thank you.
[Music]
You are new
every morning.
Each day resurrection
waiting to break through.
You are new.
[Music]